you could never really go back and do
another sitcom the fear would be how
could I ever top Seinfeld it's
guaranteed you can't top it you can't
even get close to it it's iconic it's
like all this thank you everything was
lined up everything was perfect the
casting was right I'm not arrogant and
stupid enough to think I did that so do
you I know that I got caught in a you
know what we call the perfect storm a
good one right me and Larry fit together
perfect how did you know to team up with
him in comedy certain guys it's like
it's funny right away you're talking all
of a sudden in two minutes you've hit
into something hilarious you guys start
to talk and you say hey we've got to
write a sitcom together no I had had
this meeting at NBC where they said uh
uh George Shapiro sent a note to Brandon
tarticle of one sentence call me a crazy
guy I have a feeling someday Jerry
Seinfeld is going to be doing a TV
series on NBC I had been on The Tonight
Show with Johnny Carson for nine years
nobody at NBC nobody not one person
after nine years of going on Carson
three and four times a year and killing
nobody said why don't we talk to this
kid nine years of killing on the Carson
Show should have triggered something
something nothing no so he sends this
letter I come in for the meeting they go
do you have anything you would like to
do if you ever did a show for us I said
not really great meeting I said I just
always wanted to have a meeting like
this this is what really what was the
meaning was the goal the goal
so a week later this is all true I'm
talking with Larry David at The Improv I
tell him the story
we start talking and then we go across
the street to a Korean Deli we're making
fun of everything in the deli he goes
this is what the show should be two
comedians just making fun of stuff as
they walk around during the day yeah and
that was it do you dislike when people
come up to you and start reciting what
their favorite Seinfeld episode is does
he get fatiguing after a while no I love
the episode where Kramer gets the Merv
Griffin set in his apartment thank you I
love that one too was that your concept
no it wasn't it was
um uh Bruce Eric Kaplan who was a
cartoonist for the New Yorker right who
was on our staff for a couple years what
about the masturbation episode where you
all decide that you're going to see who
can go the longest without masturbating
that was Larry David's idea NBC didn't
say uh hey you're mentioning
masturbation you never said the word
never never a while and I had the
impression you did so it worked it
worked and they there was not there was
one sponsor pulled out
one sponsor pulled out of the show that
was all I remembered in terms of any
sort of blowback on that Warren
Littlefield wrote that if you would have
given him another season in of Seinfeld
he would have paid you 110 million
dollars for the year
110 million dollars I could have got
more than that okay you could have
gotten more than that yeah and you said
no right is that the ultimate in
Integrity you were done
you know it wasn't Integrity is a nice
word and a a a flattering word I
appreciate that but
to be honest you know you know uh which
is what's fun about coming on your show
is if you just really want to be honest
right because that's what you bring to
the show okay
um the love affair between the people
that were making the show and the
audience was so intense it was so white
hot I I had to respect that and I could
not go
to that point where it starts to
age and wither and it can only be and it
doesn't take long for example you go see
a comedian
at an hour and 10 minutes you love the
guy at an hour and 30 it's like
right I thought he was never going to
finish it and all of it you walk out
with a whole different feeling it's a
small amount of too much
too much cake too much anything but do
you think it changes the whole feeling
about so we had this wonderful intense
love affair right the people are making
the show and the audience and I wanted
it to end
with a like a fireworks burst of
it never was bad and also that last
season you lost Larry David so that's
two seasons right two seasons I made it
even harder as a job right You've Lost
Your sort of it wasn't really possible
for a person to be the head writer
executive producer and star that's 24
episodes if he had just not really
humanly possible if he had stayed do you
think he might have done another season
yes yeah possibly why did he have to
leave what was his foreign Howard it's
hard work it's frustrating and it wasn't
his show it was my show that's true and
I think at that point he got the bug to
go do his own perhaps and I think it
worked out great for both of us I love
his show right I loved running the show
on my own that that turned me into
someone I never thought I could be I
never thought I could run the show on my
own and when I did thank you that was
great so I'm grateful to him for that if
I said to Young Jerry who was blabbering
away doing material there's going to be
a 110 Million Dollar Payday the final
season pretty crazy you would think you
were definitely not saying no yeah but
guess what if if you're about the money
you're gonna go just so far that's true
but don't you think the other cast
members were upset with you no we sat
and talked it over you did you went to
each other we said how do we all feel
but I I have to say I have a sense of
timing right I I have it in jokes I have
it in my sets I have it in my career I
knew when to move to LA I knew when I
was ready for The Tonight Show I knew
when I was ready for us to do something
bigger like the sitcom I just knew and I
knew that was our moment
foreign